tschechische Soldaten bei einer Übung
die Wärmebild Zielgeräte sind made in
Berlin Schritt für Schritt wurde die
Stückzahl auf 200 im Monat erhöht
Hightech und viel Handarbeit sagt der
Firmengründer über die zeitenwände haben
sie sich gefreut aber aus dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr hätten auch
sie noch nichts bekommen wir machen
eigentlich die meisten Verkäufe in an
andere europäische Armeen und dabei
fällt auf dass die sehr viel ja präziser
und schneller reagieren auf die
Situation und einfach sagen wir brauchen
bestimmte Dinge die werden erprobt und
dann werden es auch bestellt während
Deutschland immer noch in einem
Beschaffungswesen aus Friedenszeiten
verharrt seit Russlands Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine hat auch die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie ihre Produktion
hochgefahren rein Metall ist seit dieser
Woche im DAX das Düsseldorfer
Unternehmen könnte deutlich mehr Waffen
und mehr Munition liefern doch die
Branche wartet noch auf die Aufträge
wir sind jetzt in einem Modus wo man
erkannter dass man einfach vorhandene
Serien weiterführen muss dass man
Rahmenverträge ausschöpfen muss also
alles Dinge die schon da sind die
bewährt sind weitermachen das ist jetzt
das Rezept der Stunde
Boris Pistorius muss das hochkomplexe
rüstungspuzzle neu zusammenfügen und als
Verteidigungsminister muss er dafür
sorgen dass alles bezahlt wird 50
Milliarden Euro sieht der Wert ETA 2023
vor zu wenig für die vielen Aufgaben
Pistorius hätte gerne 10 Milliarden
zusätzlich als Berichterstatter für den
Einzelplan 14 Verteidigung kennt der CDU
Abgeordnete gädichens die einzelnen
Posten und weiß was auf der
Ausgabenseite steht und was nicht
viele viele andere Nationen unsere
Bündnispartner haben bereits
Bestellungen abgegeben Deutschland hängt
dort sehr hinterher und das ist eben wie
gesagt der Kardinalfehler das weder im
originärenhaushaltsplan noch im
Sondervermögen Geld für
munitionsbeschaffung eingestellt wurde
um Kapazitäten zu bündeln fordern
Experten seit langem eine neue
Aufstellung der Verteidigungsindustrie
in Europa deutlich mehr Kooperation bei
der Beschaffung bei Luftwaffe Marine und
her
erste Schritte sind auf europäischer
Ebene auch schon schon eingeleitet für
eine Verstärkung der europäischen
rüstungskooperation gemeinsame
deutsch-französische Projekte ich sehe
jetzt eigentlich vor allem die Aufgabe
der Politik diese Schritte konsequent
weiter zu verfolgen und nicht durch eine
ins Netz rein nationale zurückkippende
Beschaffung letztendlich wieder zu
konterkarieren bei der Berliner Firma
konzentrieren Sie sich jetzt auf ihr
neustes Produkt eine größere und
leistungsfähigere Wärmebildkamera um im
schwer umkämpften Rüstungsmarkt
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben
und über das Thema sprechen wir jetzt
mit dem deutschen Bundeswehrverband der
Interessen Vertretung der
bundeswehrsoldatinnen und Soldaten zu
gestaltet aus Montabaur in
Rheinland-Pfalz ist der Vorsitzende
Oberst André Wüstner schönen guten
Morgen
schönen guten Morgen immer wieder hören
wir es es dauert viel zu lange in
Deutschland Waffen Munition überhaupt
Kriegsgüter zu organisieren erklären Sie
uns noch mal warum dauert das so lange
ja weil man einfach zu spät angefangen
hat die werbeauftragte hat ja letzte
Woche in ihrem Bericht auch dargelegt
dass es zu lange dauert dass wir auch
falsche Strukturen haben und das
natürlich auch die haushaltsgesetzgebung
und all das was mit Vergabeverfahren
zusammenhängt noch in der Art und Weise
aufgestellt ist wie vor dem Krieg in dem
Kern geht es um den politischen Willen
und der war ein letzt im letzten Jahr
nicht in Gänze da jetzt ist es so dass
diese Probleme ja schon ein bisschen
länger bekannt sind dass wir jetzt
dringend mehr brauchen man könnte
natürlich auch sagen ja vielleicht liegt
es daran dass die die Unternehmen die
Rüstungsunternehmen vielleicht durch die
gestiegene Nachfrage jetzt auch einfach
nicht hinterherkommen
definitiv deswegen haben wir im letzten
Jahr eigentlich schon einen
rüstungsgipfel gefordert also eine
anderen Umgang mit der Industrie das war
unser Schwerpunkt da hat sich Politik
lange schwer getan wurde es pistorisch
ist ja derjenige der er war kaum zwei
Wochen im Amt das sofort erkannt hat und
auch angegangen ist aber es ist eben zu
spät ob bei Munition bei Ersatzteil bei
neuen Waffensystemen sie müssen sich
überlegen nämlich mal ein Beispiel wir
haben im letzten Jahr im Mai
Panzerhaubitzen abgegeben an die Ukraine
die werden jetzt erst mehr oder weniger
nachbestellt wenn in der nächsten Woche
der Haushaltsausschuss sein go gibt das
dauert alles zu lange wir haben Krieg in
Europa es muss schneller gehen der
Verteidigungsminister hat ja selbst
schon über das 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen hinaus mehr Geld
gefordert sie sagen ja selbst auch immer
die Truppe befinde sich weiter ins
Zitate freien Fall wie viel braucht es
denn aus ihrer Sicht um die Bundeswehr
langfristig richtig auszustatten
er wichtig ist jetzt dass der
Verteidigungsetat steigt Boris Pistorius
ist ja mit einer Forderung von 10
Milliarden plus ins renn gegangen ich
hoffe dass das auch jetzt am Sonntag am
Koalitionsausschuss thematisiert wird
vollkommen klar die 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen die sind ja nur für
Großprojekte es geht aber auch um
steigende Betriebskosten für Material
Infrastruktur Personal nur ein großes
Waffensystem zu kaufen ist aber dann
nicht betreiben zu können ist eben
falsch und das muss jetzt verstanden
werden deswegen ist elementar dass der
Verteidigungshaushalt steigt darauf
schaut nicht nur die Bundeswehr darauf
schaut auch die Industrie und
insbesondere unsere internationalen
Partner es geht ja gerade um
Glaubwürdigkeit mit Blick auf die
Zusagen den Ukraine aber auch mit Blick
auf die NATO selbst und da haben wir in
den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt
überzeugt und deswegen ist wichtig dass
jetzt mit einem steigenden Etat wir
nicht nur verteidigungsfähig wieder
werden sondern auch international
überzeugen trotzdem haben sie ja selber
schon gesagt nur alleine Geld wird nicht
richten
Problem sind ja auch die
beschaffungsstrukturen jetzt wollen wir
gerade wegen der Beschaffung ja in der
EU gemeinsam zum Beispiel Munition
beschaffen geht das dann ihrer Meinung
nach in die richtige Richtung
ja das ist erstmal ein gutes Ereignis
und ein gutes Signal ich bin aber ein
bisschen skeptisch was die Bürokratie
anbelangt auf europäischer Ebene und
deswegen begrüße ich das zumindest auch
die Bundesregierung sagt wir müssen auch
national mehr tun nur da bin ich beim
Punkt Kapazitäten von Industrie nehme
ich mal das Thema Munition seit letztem
Jahres bekannt dass wir zu wenig
Kapazitäten haben wir können in die
zweite und dritte Schicht im Bereich der
Industrie was wird nicht reichen das
heißt wir müssen jetzt endlich anfangen
Kapazitäten auch in Deutschland
aufzubauen beispielsweise in Sachsen
eine neue Munitionsfabrik etc sonst wird
all das nicht reichen ich nehme das
Beispiel Arterie erneut da ist es so
dass die Ukraine ein Bedarf hat an einem
Kontingent an Munition in einem Monat
das schaffen wir aktuell nur in einem
ganzen Jahr in Europa zu produzieren und
das kann nicht sein weil noch mal a hat
diese Bundesregierung Zusagen an die
Ukraine gemacht zweitens braucht die
Bundeswehr selbst Munition aber auch
Waffensysteme und Ersatzteile und
deswegen braucht es einen anderen Umgang
das auf Ebene der EU ist gut und wichtig
aber es wird alleine nicht reichen sagt
andere Wüstner vom deutschen
Bundeswehrverband der
Interessenvertretung der Soldaten und
Soldaten vielen Dank für das Interview